take the mystique of martial arts and
the blitz of prizefighting
and the training of elite level athletes
the results the Ultimate Fighting
Championship UFC is now becoming one of
the world's most popular sports instead
of a ring an eight sided cage what looks
like a collision of brute force is
actually a display of strategy anatomy
and conditioning
fighters compete in weight classes with
five-minute rounds and strict safety
rules each wears gloves specially
designed for increased protection each
athlete trains to withstand severe
impacts inside this octagonal cage
fights normally end in one of three ways
referee stoppage submission or knockout
but how good is this new breed of
fighters science we'll find out in an
arena fit for a champion a state of the
art fight studio part training gym part
laboratory with one mission uncover the
science behind mixed martial arts by
measuring the power and accuracy of
punches and kicks go by revealing
secrets of the ancient art of grappling
as well as cage fighting by examining
the physiological makeup of these
powerful New Age athletes the test
subjects are all MMA legends
for our test Tito Ortiz chooses a right
elbow strike to the side of the head I'm
gonna aim it right at the year I have
the same clinch I turn position to get
an angle on the guy now it's gonna
strike strictly right at the ear tiny
sense organs inside the ear control
equilibrium vital for maintaining
balance and orientation
like I hit it right at the eardrum when
I could fill it for my shoulder to my
hip I know it's a good strike high-speed
filming shows that Tito uses his entire
body muscles rippling from shoulder to
hip in a wave of pure energy the numbers
agree
Tito's elbow scores a hit value of 299
exceeding the benchmark ik number
required for a concussion which is 250
for the first time ever technology will
reveal what happens inside the bodies of
some of the world's most versatile
fighters this is not stuff that we've
ever seen in the lab before measuring
not only how much they can dish out but
more importantly how much they can take
you gotta be willing to go five-minute
rounds for the first time ever
the signs of mixed martial arts